So far we have focused mainly on reading data. But what
happens when we want to write to memory? Here we'll consider
a single core system. I'll refer you to an architecture class
for a shared memory system where keeping a cache consistent becomes a
challenge. We need to consider both what happens on a hit
when the block we want to write to is already in
the cache. And what happens on a miss, when it isn't.
On a hit, the most obvious thing to do is to write-through
to memory. That is, we'll write to the cache, and then
also write to the main memory to copy the data, and
keep the cache and main memory consistent. As long as I
don't have to worry about some other entity needing an updated
version from memory however, there's actually no need to write everything
this instant. This is the insight behind the write-back policy which
only writes to the cache. After all, that's where we'll look
first if the same processor tries to read the data or
write to it later. Only when the cache block gets
evicted sometime later does the data really need to be
written to main memory. And then it'll be the whole
cache block. This lazy approach can be beneficial when the same
cache block is written to many times before [INAUDIBLE]. For
cache misses we also have two strategies. The first is
write-allocate, which first reads the current value in memory into
the cache. Then it behaves as though it were a hit,
using either of the two hit strategies. Lastly we have
the no-write allocate policy, where we just write the data
to memory and don't bother with the cache at all.
The interactions among these policies can be subtle, particularly when
there are multiple cache levels. It is worth pointing out
however, that some of these policies share certain assumptions, and
are therefore often paired together. The write back policy is
betting that there will be subsequent writes to the same
cache block. That's why he is bundling up all the
changes he is making for one trip to memory, when the
block gets evicted. Write allocate is also betting on subsequent
writes to the same block. That's why he loads the data
up into the cache. On the other hand, write-through is
betting on the cache block being evicted sooner rather than later.
He does his writes to memory up front, so that
he can quickly evict the cap block from the cache later
if he has to, not having to worry about any
writes to the disk. Similarly, the no-write allocate policy is
also betting on that same cached block not being used
again soon. It doesn't even bring the data into the cache.